[Music]
so speaking of trolls let's talk about
Trump for a little bit mmm you're not
big Trump person vertices no no I I just
don't really understand how this person
who is not a politician is somehow
president now and it's very odd to me
but you know it's not him that's about
he's terrible of course but then it's
his followers that are freaky to me and
but certainly during periods of
governments that were difficult there's
always a good explosion of art that
comes around and about it so I was
around during the 80s so Reagan which
was very very much a good kind of time
for punk rock to sort of explode and and
then also during the Bush administration
serves all all of these great people
made their name on this administration
the Bush administration in particular
with John Stewart and Stephen Colbert
and Bill Maher and so you can see a a
great sort of renaissance around art
during these time so what do you think
we can do to sort of calm some of this
Trump stuff that's what I've been trying
to do I don't know that I'm succeeding
at it but I see everyone just going like
the outrage machine is just operating at
all times he tweets something we
immediately get outraged then were
outraged over the outrage of that you
know like there's just this thing that's
happening what do you think we can do to
kind of hi some of that stuff well I
think just to understand that our
government is set up so that nobody has
absolute power and that's one of the
great things about the the way the
Constitution is set up the way
everything is sort of in place so that
there's a lot of different voices
happening and that no one person has any
kind of real control so we'll see I mean
I think just getting back to politics
and Poli Sci like 101 like see
being how the American government
government actually does work yeah this
is sort of being aid to knowing that
we're ok for you know some of it we
still got to be diligent about other
things and certainly speaking out about
a lot of issues too yeah what do you
think about the sort of the state of
free speech related to him because on
one hand it's like all his supporters
seem to be all about free speech and
unpolitical
correctness and all of that stuff and I
understand that but once he's in power
are they gonna be as anti PC I suspect
not I don't know I don't know I think
there's a backlash against PC in general
it's hard to say like we just are going
to have to see I mean I don't really
know what that that that's like the
thing is the Trump bothers me but it's
just followers that really bother me a
lot yeah that's what's really strange
and really scary
yeah do you sense that there's something
else going on here I mean a lot of
people are saying that this is like
unfurling this white supremacy stuff and
all that and it's like I kind of see it
and then on the other hand I'm like
they're just trolling and I don't know I
don't know it's everybody's truly the
president oh it's so so what is that I
mean so what does that say as someone
that's been in entertainment all the
time that we have an entertainment
president now like what does that say
about us do you know no but he's not
even really an entertainer because no
entertainer really likes him either so
like it's like not any of entertainment
really supports him or has supported him
really I mean there's a lot of us know
him they of course he's he's somebody
that people know but he's not somebody
that people like hang with they're like
you've never really fit in right in
terms of like Hollywood or any of that
you know weird wait does that make you
like him sort of because as an outsider
right like there's some outsider piece
that it's like anything like a certain
amount of people are like oh he's the
outsider that's what they like no I
guess what I don't know it's weird I
have no idea yeah what do you think the
the Democrats can do to kind of regroup
here well we can really make sure that
our rights are protected make sure that
you know that we vote next time also uh
you blame Hillary for that that just
sort of the turn I mean I know she ended
up getting more popular than you do but
that there was just sort of the feeling
of like you know the Bernie people were
kind of upset about what happened and
that the younger people were kind of
depressed you think that sort of oh
there's a lot of no it's not her fault
but it was the the there's a lot of
misogyny there's a lot of ideas about
how could we have a woman president I
think a woman we define president she
would have been a fine president yeah
fine politician but well thank all the
men were so great at it you know yeah I
know it's just a lot of it's the highest
hardest glass ceiling and she's right
about that it's so true yeah everything
being equal would you view that as a
piece that would make you vote for
somebody if you if you were just looking
at two people that you felt that they
were really exactly the same when I
would be about breaking the ceiling yeah
I would tend to vote for a woman for
sure yeah I mean and it's like there is
no all things being equal because if
you're a woman and politics you have to
be so exceptional to get anywhere you
know you have to be so much better at
any I mean this is true of all fields I
believe that are male-dominated for a
woman to be successful you have to be
better and stronger and this awesome you
know you have to be so good in order to
sort of get the same accolades as your
male counterparts yeah how aware that
were you in in like your early stand-up
days that you had to be like because
stand-up really is a boys club it's
really a straight male Club that one
happens to be were you always very aware
that you had to be like on point more
than they did and and I had to be more
devoted to it I had to love it I had to
be just really involved but that's my
nature I love the art form and so I
don't really care I'm going to work
harder at it than anybody though I mean
that's just I have to yeah so stand-up
you would say is your greatest artistic
oh yeah for sure it's my it's it's it's
my life I mean it's all I care about you
know I love it more than anything
yeah your process do you just go out
there with new bits and just try to work
them on the flyer you know everybody has
a little different thing everybody's
different I I will write some things out
and try to figure that out usually
what's better is if I am working on
something and then I sort of just work
it out on stage there's something about
the adrenaline that makes you kind of go
for something better but I and I also do
shows every day more than once a day
several times a day yeah I can yeah
do you like like the intimate small club
crowd or like a big theatre oh good it's
all good
I like the little belly room at the
Comedy Store and I like little shows
like little open mics I'll do I just did
a big arena show with Kevin Hart which
was awesome and that's very different -
yeah this is huge arena full of people
and it's great you know it's almost like
a totally different thing in a way right
cuz ya play with the crowd you can't be
here at work Connie can but you're also
in the round and you're also working
with the camera guy who are like
focusing on the audience coming to you
like so it's all these different factors
that make it different from a
traditional stand-up show yeah when you
do your specials like how much do you
plan out like this hour like I've got to
say something I have to shock some
people I have to do what's funny like do
you really like get that whole process
yeah you're eight it as as specifically
as that but that's sort of like you have
ingredients it's like okay this is miss
shock this much like love rich whatever
it's got to go in there um sort of a
witch's brew no real sense of like an
exact recipe but there is one yeah I did
you ever see the Seinfeld documentary
comedian and there's that great moment
where him and Shandling are in the car
and Jerry's got like you know pages of
like stuff and it's like written out
like a you know like a tactician and
Shandling pulls out this like crumpled
piece of paper and I thought that was
just such a beautiful moment because
they loved each other so much they so
respected it and yet they did it
differently that's sort of the beauty of
stand-up right yeah I mean Jerry's great
Jerry's such a he is such a
craftsman you know he's just
everything's perfect and it's all like
mathematical to like everything it's
analytical mathematical he's it's it's
really a genius way of working and he
calls my comedy
what is the artisanal handmade jewelry
comedy but that I'm like they go they
like a table on you know with like on
Sunday selling it at an Art Fair that's
his sort of analogy of my comedy which i
think is great right but he's he's a
genius
I love Jerry and and Gary of course yeah
so you just did comedians in cars
getting coffee right how was it driving
around in a car caffeinated with Jerry
so fun I loved I loved him and you know
he's just a really good friend and
somebody I've known for a very very long
time somebody I really adore and and
somebody that I just I'm a huge fan of
his comedy as well you know he's a
legend what does it say about him do you
think that like he still to me I saw me
stand-up maybe a year ago and I had done
shows with him you know years before
just like not that I was booked before
but you know when you do in New York
City shows and someone just walks in and
happens to be there but that he's still
on the top of his game despite having
that much money that would hurry out
like what do you think that is like that
drive to keep doing so loves it like he
loves comedy he really laughs like if he
you know he's like like his his choice
is to watch stand-up comedy like if he's
like you know trying to sort of like
watch something he's going to watch that
special he's going to watch who he
thinks is great like he's if you're like
hanging out with them and you're like
making a joke he really laughs like it's
like somebody who's so in love with the
art form and it's so good at it and you
know just wants to elevate it no matter
what whether he's watching it or doing
it he's going to elevate it and that's
what makes him a master yeah do you
think the money they'll ruin some of
these guys I don't see that with him but
I do see it there are some other people
I can either name a couple or not that'd
be that I feel like they get to a
certain point a success and then it just
is sort of about maintaining
I don't know you know the people that
are truly brilliant always reach for
higher you know and it the the success
is it's fine
but you were chasing something much more
ethereal much harder to get that money
yeah you know what is it what is it what
is it that you're chasing the brilliance
of a good joke the brilliance of
figuring out what that is for you I've
only really achieved it a couple of
times in my life and I I feel like very
few comedians actually really get there
and you know there's people like I think
taking guitar oh is one who continually
does it for me bill burr always Bobby
Lee always Ali Wong very much so
louis c.k perfect example of that like
this perfect culmination of what you do
it's really it's magic to us Oh Todd
Todd Barry yeah I love Todd Todd is
really good I used to see him doing
stand-up in New York and it was just
like he was basically winging it the
whole time that's at least the way I saw
it sounds that's what that's what it
sounds like but then I realized wait a
minute this guy's not winging this no it
is it's really prepared but then there
was a tour where he did what he did
right oh he did a whole tour where it
was just crowd work basically yeah like
that right it's so funny
so basically do you think that more than
anything else it's about just being in
your truth as a comic like really just
finding the artistic way to just express
set perfect Dave Chappelle is very good
at it very perfect truths very Chris
Rock is very good it's almost like a
haiku something is just perfect jokes uh
you know but Jerry's the best I think
that perfect that I don't know it's like
it's so ethereal and hard to pick and
it's also hard to do like if you have it
it's hard to repeat it because it's like
from their voice and their point of view
has to do with what they look like what
they're saying it's all the stuff yeah
you think there's something like
particularly crazy about the art of
stand-up in that we do it you're getting
the reaction to men
moment you're doing like a painter
doesn't paint something and then turn to
somebody and be like that's real good
but comics we need that right to figure
out if what you did was right you're
constantly the approval factor I guess
is like ramped up with stand-up in a way
that it's not with other art yeah like
you have to be a certain brand of crazy
for that don't you
I think so but in you need the approval
every like 10 seconds yeah it's not just
like it you have to have it every 10
seconds I'm also big believer in LPM
laughs permit yeah yeah you have to have
a hile pammer it's not gonna work like
it's just just not so are you gonna win
the Grammy for American myth I mean how
important is that to you like you know I
assume you want to win it right oh god
yeah you don't to pretend you don't want
to win it I have to win it I got to win
yes sir five times yeah who we up
against a very great people Patton
amazing David Cross amazing Amy Schumer
amazing TIG Notaro amazing all of them
it's a it's a it's a it's a tough battle
they're all great and they're all
deserving you know all of us are
deserving but I have I'm five times more
desert yeah naturally fired only because
I I've been on you've been nominated a
couple of times yeah uh you're also Emmy
nominated yeah acting it's a great yeah
it's just like it's just like extra fun
sort of like yeah I mean it's it's
always different you know I'm not on a
show right now so it's I'm doing all
sorts of different stuff it's not none
of it really kind of is this sort of the
same I never get typecast for anything
except you know live Asian but actually
it's always different so yeah so do you
feel that pressure anymore so we're that
in 94 where maybe there was some
pressure to represent Asian people or
whatever and you know do you feel that
now like because now you're so like your
own thing like if someone says we're
putting Margaret Cho anything like I
feel like you only represent yourself
but you feel a little extra pressure
from your quantity or something no no I
mean I'm an elder statesman now you know
like I I order you you can
you know 4848 elder statesman it is yeah
in this game yeah for comedy for sure
and I mean all of it is good like I
don't really ever think specifically
like oh you know I have to do anything
differently I'm just doing it yeah so
what's what's next after after this
after you win the Grammy well what's the
next move you got to go for you've been
Emmy nominated too so gotta get that
after where what are we looking at here
Andy got any weird 30 rock thing yeah
Emmy Grammy Oscar Tony you got totally
uh I have done off-broadway not Broadway
yeah that'd be fun yeah does that appeal
to you yes for sure
yeah so basically you just want to throw
stuff against the wall and kind of stir
it all cuz bands yeah yeah um this has
been a pleasure talking to you I feel
like we kind of like it was we did like
a typewriter thing here we kind of
nailed everything to me yeah we went
everything we're down yeah all right
well it was a pleasure you know we did
this once on the phone.i Sirius XM show
years ago I don't know what you were
doing exactly but we ended up talking
for a half-hour about you were in a
forest in a cabin like you were stoned I
need any recollection sounds like Sweden
yeah like I spend a lot of time in
Scandinavia oh I think you were in
Sweden actually as we had to dial in
some crazy numbers yeah it sounds like
Sweden yeah what are you doing Sweden I
do comedy there I do well I do comedy
all over Scandinavia all over Europe but
I spent a lot of time especially like in
the forest in a cabin like crunch crunch
good very cool yeah do you like doing
stand-up in different places like how
often do you find like the crowds are
real their sensibilities you ever have
to ship [ __ ] right no they're great I
love it it's so fun and they just are so
excited you know I love I love going to
Europe it's so intimate and different
and and and I feel like very special to
people to do that a lot of American
comedians can't do that so I get to do
all over Britain all over your
all over Asia Australia it's very
special you mean can't do it like there
acts don't translate yeah or they just
don't go or they don't want to go yeah
no but I love it yeah
you ever miss like just sort of a
normalcy you know it I mean like just
the normal life that people I don't know
what it would be like I mean I I grew up
in comedy so I don't know what a normal
existence would be I'm not sure yeah you
know it's cool I'm happy this seems
better
this is he it seems good I'm not sure
what normal is you know I have friends
who have kids and jobs and that seems to
be harder but this is actually pretty
hard yeah I love it them yeah alright
well it was a pleasure talking to you I
have a feeling five is gonna be the
charm
what do you think you're pretty well I'm
also a hosting so I mean it low but does
that work against you because then it's
weird no no even if I don't win I'm
gonna grab it out of the winners hands
cuz I'll be on the stage a did you I
don't know if you remember anymore if he
did that one year who did he grab it
from I feel like he grabbed it out of it
might have been George Carlin's hands
but I'm not sure but if he was hosting
right and um they were given their
speech and he just walked past and
grabbed it and walked off and it was so
funny yeah so maybe so one way or
another you're walking I'm gonna grab me
yeah alright well I have a feeling she's
gonna win the Grammy and for more on
Margaret and her tour dates and all the
other stuff she's doing
check out Margaret Cho
[Music]
you